tout ce que vous dites pour être retenu
contre vous c'est vrai en justice c'est
vraiment politique en particulier quand
les caméras enregistrent le ministre de
l'Éducation Bernard Dreville le sait
évidemment il l'a ré appris à ses
dépenses à la suite d'une entreprise
éditoriale avec les collègues du devoir
pendant cette entrevue le chroniqueur
Michel David lui demande comment il
explique le fait que bientôt les députés
de l'Assemblée nationale seront payés
plus cher que leurs collègues des autres
provinces mais que les enseignants du
Québec seront moins payés ou sont moins
payés que leurs collègues des autres
promesses c'est la réponse de Monsieur
Drainville qui fait controverse réponse
qu'on vous fera entendre dans un instant
le temps de vous présenter ceux qui se
prêtent au jeu de la table éditoriale
tous les jours Michel Jean-François
Dimitri et Françoise bon début
d'après-midi à vous quatre
bonjour bonjour alors on va écouter
l'échange ça dure une bonne minute mais
notez le ton le langage corporel aussi
dans cet échange d'environ une minute
qu'on écoute
100000 l'enseignants du Québec
qui ne gagne pas suffisamment je suis
d'accord je voudrais le randonner plus
il vient de négociation qui est en cours
présentement
puis
c'est pas le spot je trouve que la
comparaison est un petit peu boiteuse et
si je m'appelais Michel David je dirais
qu'elle est un tantinet démagogique
pourquoi donc
pourquoi un député
le job d'enseignante à la job de député
là tu étais en train de me dire que ça
se compare je dis pas qu'un député doit
être payé le même prix qu'un enseignant
je dis que c'est un député il peut être
payé aussi cher plus cher que ces
confrères au Canada anglais je vois pas
pourquoi un enseignant serait pas payé
aussi cher je souhaite que les
enseignants et les enseignants soient le
mieux payé possible
ok alors l'interprétation qui a été
donnée aux propos de Monsieur drinville
c'est dire il apporte il donne moins de
valeur à la fonction d'enseignants que
celle de député vous Jean-François vous
interprétez ça comme
il était complètement désarmé par la
question évidemment et la question de
base c'est la comparaison avec le reste
du Canada puisque dans cette
augmentation de salaire scandaleuse au
taux donné au députés par laque les
députés du rassemblée nationale de
deviendront les plus payés de toutes les
assemblées provinciales pas du fédéral
qui sont bien trop payés à mon avis mais
de alors là mon ami Michel David dit
pourquoi est-ce que dans ce cas là les
enseignants du Québec ne devraient pas
être pas plus payé que la moyenne
canadienne mais au moins aussi payer que
la moyenne canadienne plus on peut
débattre que le coût de la vie est moins
cher au Québec quand Ontario c'est ce
qu'on fait toujours dans les
négociations avec les employés de l'État
mais c'est drôle cet argument là polaire
à être prégnant pour les députés aussi
parce que aussi le coût de la vie est
moins cher pour les députés pas
seulement pour les enseignants alors
plutôt que la seule bonne réponse
c'était une partie de sa réponse de dire
je suis d'accord avec toi les
enseignants sont pas suffisamment payés
d'ailleurs il faut dire que la CAQ avant
lui a augmenté de 15% le salaire
d'entrée des enseignants ce qui est très
bien et on apprenait aujourd'hui qui
veulent offrir 12000 dollars à un
enseignant qui restreint un an après sa
retraite ce qui est très bien alors donc
en fait la carte a un dossier qui est
plutôt positif sur le salaire des
enseignants mais Bernard drinville je
l'appelle Bernard si mon ancien collègue
des de du Conseil des ministres Bernard
aéré en abordant le sujet que c'est pas
comparable le travail d'un député puis
d'un enseignant je lui donne raison
c'est bien plus difficile d'être
enseignant que députés parce que j'ai
aucun doute qu'un bon enseignante
secondaire pourrait être dans la chaise
d'un député pendant une semaine
évidemment la difficulté c'est de se
faire élire mais une fois que tu es élu
la capacité intellectuelle nécessaire
pour être député la charge mentale en
tout cas est moins grande que celle de
devoir gérer 30 étudiants dont 10 sont
en difficulté scolaire alors évidemment
tout le monde va dire monsieur drinville
on vous invite à venir une semaine gérer
ma classe puis voir si vous n'avez pas
être en burn out le mercredi après-midi
bon et puis évidemment c'est un c'est un
cadeau au négociateur de l'éducation des
enseignants pour dire vous voyez là vous
avez vous devez corriger maintenant la
table de négociation la bourde du
ministre de l'éducation à la table
éditoriale on va en parler dans un
instant des négociations je vais vous
présenter un tweet de Marwa risqué parce
que Jean-François Marwa risky va un peu
dans le sens dans lequel vous allez
aussi puis elle est très elle est habile
madame risky pour récupérer les choses
j'ai été prof à l'Université malgré
cette expérience j'étais brûlée après
une semaine à titre d'enseignants dans
une classe de 5e année après plusieurs
mois de suppléance je peux affirmer
qu'un enseignant peut-être un excellent
député mais l'inverse est moins vrai
donc qu'un député député ne peut pas
être un bon enseignant vrai bref elle
l'a récupéré à sa façon avec un petit
sourire et d'imiter avant de vous donner
la parole Bernard drinville a sorti le
besoin de faire le point ce matin sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment sur
Twitter en disant ceci en aucun cas j'ai
voulu insinuer que le travail
d'enseignant à moins d'importance que
celui de député à mes yeux toutes les
professions et tous les métiers méritent
le même respect qu'on soit enseignante
infirmière machiniste plombier etc et il
ajoute j'ai aussi déclaré dans
l'entrevue puis si on vous a passé
debout que je souhaitais que les
enseignants soient mieux rémunérés mais
que cette question devait se régler à la
table de négociation rappelons que notre
gouvernement a augmenté le salaire des
enseignants de 14 à 18% une hausse
historique vous voyez ça comment Dimitri
j'ai un plus grand problème avec le
tweet de Madame risky que les propos du
ministre de Dainville et je vais vous
dire pourquoi
premièrement c'est vrai le ministre de
Rainville n'a jamais insinué que le rôle
de député était plus important que celui
de l'enseignant chaque rôle dans notre
société à son importance parce que c'est
tous les morceaux de ce puzzle avec les
plombiers les chirurgies
que nous sommes capables de fournir des
services à notre société mais quand
madame risquid dit qu'elle était
professeur à l'université et après
quelques jours à une école secondaire
elle était brûlée tout ce que ça veut
dire c'est que elle est une mauvaise
prof pour une école primaire ou
secondaire et sa vocation
avec le courant juste pour être pour les
techniques corrects sa vocation son
Excellence c'était d'être une excellente
prof à l'Université moi aussi j'ai
essayé d'aider mon job qui est plombier
puis après deux jours j'étais brûlé
aussi ça veut dire que je suis un
mauvais plombier et de dire que un prof
peut être un meilleur un prof peut
devenir député mais on peut pas dire
l'inverse encore une fois on minimise et
on insulte l'importance de nos 125
représentants à l'Assemblée nationale
pourquoi est-ce qu'un député ne peut pas
être aussi bon prof qu'un prof peut être
un aussi bon député et quand la question
de Monsieur David c'est important de
regarder l'échange entre le ministre
Drainville et et et Monsieur David
c'est clair un député devrait avoir un
salaire plus élevé que le salaire d'un
professeur regarde les salaires des
profs au Québec Jean-François vous
l'avez mentionné ça commence à 40 45000
et ça peut aller jusqu'à 90 000 par
année donc encore une fois pourquoi
est-ce que on sème la zizanie sur un
enjeu ou et on minimise l'importance de
nos députés vous savez encore une fois
je le répète c'est les 125 individus
homme et femme chargés de la
bienveillance et du bon fonctionnement
de notre démocratie donc je suis
beaucoup plus dérangé par le tweet de
Madame risky qui qui dénigre et qui
minimise
nos députés c'est juste quelqu'un qui
s'assoit il vote sur des lois presque à
chaque jour donc leur importance dans
notre société est primordiale selon et
avoir des salaires plus élevés et avoir
des salaires plus élevés va faire en
sorte qu'on va pouvoir attirer plus de
gens regardez qu'est-ce qui se passe
fédéral que ce soit parti libéral aux
parties conservateurs la vaste majorité
puis on regardait les partiels tous les
candidats de tous les partis que ce soit
madame guéri que ce soit le candidat
conservateur à portée c'est tous des
gens qui étaient avant de devenir
candidat était du personnel politique
donc on veut attirer plus de gens que
des gens qui font de la politique une
carrière depuis l'âge de 16 ans est-ce
que les profs au Québec devrait gagner
l'équivalent de la moyenne canadienne
pour les profs ou les enseignants du
reste du Canada Dimitri selon selon les
coûts de la vie puis Jean-François la
mentionné il faut s'assurer que nos
profs sont bien rémunérés parce que
encore une fois le rôle d'un professeur
est un rôle primordial ils sont en train
d'élever la prochaine génération qui va
prendre la relève mais de créer une une
controverse autour des propos du
ministre en ville il n'a pas minimisé le
rôle des profs mais mais ce que je dis
c'est un député devrait être payé plus
qu'un professeur et pas de vacances
d'été en passant
ça c'est nouveau c'est nouveau
je suis je suis mais je suis certain
vous étiez pas deux ou trois mois de
vacances n'est-ce pas Michel non mais on
avait des vacances quand même
moins que les enseignants mais plus que
la moyenne des travailleurs absolument
et mon Dieu je vais vous dire en droit
du travail la notion de comparable c'est
extrêmement difficile quand on fait des
des travaux d'équité d'équité salariale
pas je dis pas d'égalité salariale mais
d'équité donc un poste après dominance
etc est équivalent à quel est son
équivalence c'est un jeu dangereux je
dis ça pourquoi parce que
moi je dis c'est la faute à Bernard
drinville malheureusement
Bernard dans sa candeur parce que moi
aussi je vais l'appeler Bernard parce
qu'après tout le monde par son prénom
il y a pas développer sa pensée et ça
donnait sa prêter le flanc à tout cette
énergie sur les réseaux sociaux
absolument incroyables parce que il a
ouvert cette porte et il a été surtout
incapable de répondre à la question
principale de Michel David qui était de
dire ouais mais avec le reste du Canada
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec nos
enseignants et ça c'était une question
importante et il aurait pu dire garder
j'ai une concert qui travaille bien fort
au Conseil du Trésor là dans ces
négociations il y avait des réponses
tellement simples mais Bernard et
Bernard
et c'est ça qu'il avait l'air il avait
l'air pas prêt il y avait pas l'air
préparé et tu t'en vas pas t'asseoir
avec Michel David du devoir pas préparé
Pipo que ton équipe en tout cas ils sont
directeur de com puis ces gens de
politique là ont peut-être pas fait du
travail mais le ministre non plus en
leur disant pas quel genre de questions
ce que Michel David va s'apprêter à me
faire voyons donc c'était des questions
tellement de base et en 10 ans veux-tu
vraiment comparer le ça prête le flan à
dire comme Dimitri qui voulait pas les
dénigrer mais je voulais juste pas
entrer dans ce jeu-là ou ça voulait dire
parce qu'avec le temps il faut regarder
le non verbal vous en avez parlé en
début moi je l'ai écouté de bains des
façons son extrait j'écoutais chanson je
l'ai écouté avec du son et l'impression
que ça donne c'est quelqu'un qui était
excédé par la question et qui les
faisait un genre
et puis moi si je dis plus comme ça là
les gens vont dire ben franchement là
c'est pas très poli et ça donne une
impression un peu réducteur dans dans la
chose et puis je vous dirais la chose
suivante il y a beaucoup de gens qui
comparent l'Assemblée nationale à une
salle de classe en passant parce qui
sont tellement disponibles moi je dirais
que comme comparable comme comparable
pour la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale une professeure de classe ou
un directeur ou directrice d'école c'est
pas mal comparable par c'est pas mal le
travail qu'elle a à faire puis les
autres c'est des élèves je sais pas
combien on paye les étudiants au Québec
mais ça serait peut-être intéressant à
regarder il y aurait pu éviter tout ça
s'il avait été préparé point
pendant ce temps là il y a une
négociation Michel dans le secteur
public OK et puis là il y a le Bernard
drinville qui parle des enseignants de
cette façon-là c'est interprété de
toutes sortes de façon les députés sont
sur le point où vont se voter une
augmentation de salaire de 30000 dollars
le directeur de cabinet de François Hugo
donc du Premier ministre a reçu une
augmentation de 70 000 dollars et on
offre 2% d'augmentation par année sur 5
ans au fonctionnaires aux employés de la
fonction publique ce qui laisse Sonia
Lebel président du Conseil du Trésor
dans une drôle de situation c'est comme
si elle reçoit des des balles de neige
ses collègues puis elle essaie de
négocier en même temps avec la fonction
publique voici ce qu'elle avait à dire
ce matin
c'est sûr que c'est pas un environnement
idéal pour négociation puisqu'on prend
les gens de s'y perdre un peu et de
regarder ça de façon très froide puis de
dire waouh on n'est pas dans la même
dans la même dans la même façon de faire
mais c'est vrai mais on est on compare
pas les mêmes choses donc on est très
juste équitable malgré tout
c'est pas un environnement idéal mais on
est très juste et équitable malgré tout
vous voyez ça commence
mais ça tient pas ça tient pas vraiment
la route et c'est évident que le
contexte pour le dit la semaine dernière
de l'augmentation du salaire des élus et
très mal choisi la période est très mal
choisie dans notre atmosphère de
négociation et tout va reposer sur les
épaules de de Madame Lebel et elle se
retrouve un peu seule finalement avec la
patate chaude la négociation et c'est
son rôle de le faire et là ce matin elle
nous annonce des prêts moi je voudrais
parler de ça un peu des primes aux
enseignants des primes aux infirmières
et ce gouvernement là a beaucoup
misé sur l'ajout de près mon logiciel
on le fait oui si vous permettez pour
les enseignants par exemple c'est
la retraite pour les garder au travail
un an plus on leur donne 12000 dollars
une prime de 12000 vous pour le
personnel enseignant admissible à la
retraite on leur donne 12000 dollars
puis les ressources en santé et un
service sociaux
143 millions de dollars de prime
prolongées jusqu'à la fin de l'été donc
on prolonge les primes
oui voilà donc à chaque fois qu'elles
vont s'arrêter ça va ils vont se reposer
la même question est-ce qu'on est
prolonge encore et encore mais c'est là
que janvier Jean-François moi je ne peux
de difficulté avec ça je peux comprendre
que dans certaines situations
exceptionnelles on veuille puis j'ai
déjà utilisé aussi des primes dans des
situations exceptionnelles en
négociation mais là c'est ça une
tendance à devenir un peu la norme et et
toujours pour mettre un peu un dial
silence sur un bobo bien précis et ça ça
je trouve ça un peu dérangeant parce que
pendant ce temps-là on le sait très bien
que les conditions de travail des
enseignants des infirmières il faut
regarder tout ça globalement mais il
faut aussi les conditions de travail des
deux corps de métier d'une certaine
cette façon et et qu'on évite à chaque
fois de de relancer des débats sur la
façon dont on organise le travail tant
dans le réseau de la santé que dans le
réseau de l'éducation et en quelque part
c'est un peu à l'encontre aussi des
revendications des syndicats un peu
comme si on mettait des syndicats de
côté puis c'est comme si ça existait pas
puis nous nous le bon gouvernement à
tous les deux trois mois
on agite une carotte
j'ajoute je demande l’offre 143 millions
par ci pour ne fait ça il y a à peu près
quoi une coupe de moi aussi après avoir
offert un pourcentage d'augmentation
juste avant Noël deux jours avant Noël
qui avait aucun sens parce que face à
l'inflation c'était nettement
insuffisant et ça je trouve que c'est
aussi en quelque part et je vais peser
mes mots mais un certain manque de fait
ou de
qui ne sait pas suffisamment compte de
la réalité de ces enseignantes ou de ses
infirmières sur le terrain et
négociation ça se fait autour de table
vous dites la réalité c'est comme si on
leur offre de l'argent puis on dit
l'argent va faire leur bonheur moi
franchement Sébastien si j'étais
enseignante ou si j'étais infirmière
j'aurai le sentiment qu'on veut
m'acheter du certaines façons puis qu'on
veut m'acheter avec un 12000 dollars
pour que j'apprenne ma retraite plus
tard que et que m'achète encore avec une
prime pour que cet été je fasse du temps
supplémentaire ou je ne sais trop et je
trouve ça
dérangeant parce que c'est pas ça de
négociation de convention collective et
c'est pas de cette façon là qu'on va
assurer une sorte de stabilité de de
fonctionnement et qu'on va reconnaître
la valeur du travail de nos enseignants
et de nos infirmières particulièrement
dans un contexte de pénurie
particulièrement dans un contexte où
c'est difficile pour toutes sortes de
raisons mais des raisons qui sont
importantes et d'autres faut tenir
compte parce que à la fin il y a
toujours un service à offrir à la
population que ce soit nos enfants ou
que ce soit aux personnes malades alors
je trouve qu'il y a une certaine
désinvolture c'est une stratégie c'est
une stratégie parmi d'autres mais je
pense que les syndicats devraient tenir
leur bout et questionner cette stratégie
là et dénoncer cette stratégie là avec
un peu plus de force mais en même temps
ils savent très bien qu'ils n'ont pas le
gros bout du bâton non plus parce que
c'est le gouvernement qui va décider
c'est lui qui a l'argent peut-être que
le gouvernement essaie de diviser un peu
les syndiqués en disant il va y avoir
des syndicats qui vont s'indiquer qui
vont avoir des primes deux problèmes
avec les primes semble-t-il problème
fondamental avec les primes c'est que ça
compte pas pour la retraite
pour avoir des primes pendant plusieurs
années ça compte pas pour ta retraite
l'autre problème avec la prime de 12000
dollars en fait ce matin aux enseignants
retraités les syndicats nous disent les
retraités ils ont rempli leurs papiers
au mois d'avril 3 4 mois déjà ils sont
prêts à aller à la retraite et là ils
ont planifié leur affaire de retraite
puis il y a des leurs postes a été donné
à des gens qui vont occuper les salles
la fonction dans la salle du prof qui
qui va à la retraite bref ça va être et
croyez-moi-le Sébastien c'est la chose
la plus complexe dans le réseau scolaire
cette capacité d'agencer les postes aux
enseignants en fonction de oui
l'ancienneté mais en fonction des des
codes maladies parce qu'il y a
énormément de maladies dans le réseau et
dans les congés de maternité et les
retraites c'est d'une complexité
incroyable bonne chance Bernard
semble-t-il il a deux soeurs qui sont
enseignants
on va faire des belles parties de
famille
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI